[Música]
ah
i
bueno quienes están acá han escuchado
alguna vez algunas charlas sobre
emprendedorismo son emprendedores
emprendedoras
o han visto quienes han visto realmente
la mano quien ha visto vacunas han leído
libros o ámbitos
vídeos youtube
bastantes y yo les pido cinco palabras
que le vengan a la mente pensando en
emprendedores que me dirían a ver
creatividad ver
como confianza que más
pasión innovación
talento nuevos paradigmas y tenemos 5
a mí me tocó ya hace varios años
arrancar un proyecto que en realidad
terminó siendo una empresa cuando
todavía estas cosas no se hablaban o no
se conocían así técnicamente es más yo
tengo una anécdota del año 2002 un
sábado estaba almorzando con la familia
del restaurant y de la mesa no se
levanta una chica y se acerca y me
pregunta a mí si me llamo su sistema si
le digo que se moza que quería a ver si
podría juntarme con vos charlar porque
sé que tiene una empresa yo quiero armar
una empresa y quería preguntarte qué es
lo que habría que hacer que me sugería
en ese momento aproveche que estaba con
las bocas llenas para pensar un poco
pero me di cuenta que no sabía
no se me pasó nada de qué decirle
y en más si bien después charlábamos nos
juntábamos y algunas cosas y fui
elaborando pero en ese momento también
me di cuenta que lo que me había pasó a
mí no tenía conciencia de lo que había
hecho para llegar a donde había llegado
ese momento ya la empresa estaba en
varios países tenemos más de 150
empleados pero la verdad que no sabía
qué es lo que había que hacer y mucho
menos tampoco tenía conciencia lo que
había hecho por supuesto que a partir de
ahí empecé a leer sobre el tema
interesarme más a conferencia que hay
participar es más yo en este momento
participó de distintas organizaciones
que promueven emprendedurismo
soy parte de la fundación endeavour soy
mentor de otros emprendedores y desde
aquel momento
vengo viendo mucho y estudiando mucho y
la verdad que hoy cuando me preguntan
puedo decir muchas cosas
pero sin embargo me queda siempre algo
algo una pregunta pregunta final que es
entender un poco más qué pasa para el
primer paso porque todo lo que creo que
la gran mayoría escuchado cosas le dio
libro ha visto vídeo que pues me dijeron
acá todos sabemos que aparte esas cosas
que usted dijeron emprender significa
voluntad significa salida sonar confort
significa animarse entonces y también se
habla mucho lo que es lo que hay que
hacer con un emprendimiento cuando
cuando arrancó el emprendimiento creo
que tengo que hacer ahora yo lo que
siento a veces cuando me preguntan a
cuando me consultan es como hace una
persona para arrancar y para el primer
paso
porque hay digamos a todas las teorías
pero hay que estar en ese lugar y
animarse a arrancar
y entonces acá para reflexionar sobre
esto les quería mencionar una una la
frase que define qué es un emprendedor
una emprendedora hay muchas pero voy a
usar esta porque me sirve para lo que
les quiero comunicar y dice que un
emprendedor o una emprendedora es una
persona con capacidades
para detectar oportunidades y
desarrollar una organización una
respuesta para aprovecharla
dice que es una persona con capacidades
para detectar oportunidades y
capacidades para desarrollar una
respuesta a una organización algo que
ver que aproveche esa oportunidad
y comprime en un tema una primer palabra
sola que quiere hacer hincapié es el
tema de las oportunidades porque también
parecería que emprender en una sola
receta y todos pueden emprender y todos
pueden llegar a lo mismo y en realidad
también las oportunidades son gran parte
de la vida y la historia y la evolución
del emprendedor porque la verdad es que
nosotros vamos moldeando nos con las
oportunidades que se nos van dando y
entonces la misma persona que empieza a
hacer determinados proyecto empieza a
emprender y estas cosas se empieza a
dedicar a ciertos temas más allá de lo
que tenga personalmente como como sueño
como como proyecto
te va cambiando la vida y las
oportunidades te van cambiando si bien
es cierto que también los emprendedores
muchas veces generan oportunas que no
están en prevención gente que no sólo
detecta oportunidad sino que a veces las
inventan y crean oportunidad nueva pero
esas oportunidades y las historias las
oportunidades van moldeando y van
haciendo que los emprendedores sean muy
diversos muy diversos en la forma en lo
que hacen hay emprendedores que pueden
generar organizaciones emprendedores
sociales emprendedores culturales y
emprender es chicos más grandes
emprendedores que a lo mejor son
emprender extiendo incluso trabajando en
una empresa
y esto es un tema importante saber que
no existe un modelo de emprendedor único
sino que depende mucho también de las
oportunidades pero la otra parte que
decía la frase dice que es una persona
con capacidades
y acá en un tema importante porque hay
una discusión siempre si las capacidades
que tienen o se pueden formar yo creo
que hay gente que viene con capacidades
innatas que no saben por qué pero
también estoy convencido que se puede
formar y cultivar y hacer crecer las
capacidades para poder emprender
pero hay una cosa importante y lo que
quiero que reflexionemos hoy es que
también es importante que las
capacidades hay que formarlas antes de
arrancar con los emprendimientos con los
proyectos o antes de empezar con la
oportunidades
la verdad que si no nos genera esas
capacidades y unas cultiva si no las
tiene el momento que parece la
oportunidad nos da vida dejar pasar no
lo voy a ver
esto es importante que las capacidades
se formen desde antes de que uno se
plantee arrancar y también una receta
para decir cuando cuando hablamos esto
desde el miedo de cómo arrancar la
verdad que antes de arrancar todo que
pensaron antes de decir bueno empezar a
formar lo que se llama una actitud
emprendedora porque en definitiva
emprender es una actitud de vida es una
forma de encarar los problemas de una
forma de ver las oportunidades que por
supuesto cuando se presentan la
oportunidades terminan muchas veces
siendo ciertos proyectos pero más que
nada emprender es una actitud de vida y
acá yo hoy quiero que reflexión no
solamente sobre cuatro puntos 4
aspectos de estas capacidades que yo
creo que hay que generar y también hacer
una reflexión un poco porque a veces lo
que yo veo lo que yo escucho uno ve
siempre que se hablan cosas muy fáciles
y bueno el primer tema aquí lo tratemos
es la pasión todo es muy bueno para ser
uno de los emprendedores tiene que ser
gente apasionada entonces es fácil
decirlo pero que como se lo como se hace
uno es apasionado y otra cosa que se
habla mucho parece que la forma de tener
pasión es hacer el proyecto que uno el
sueño que uno quiere
el proyecto que uno lo único que uno
siempre estuvo aspirando yo me parece
que la única forma de estar apasionado
es cuando realmente estoy haciendo lo
que quiero
pero acá yo creo que hay una trampa y
acá yo y los invito a que ustedes con
hablen con emprendedores cuando escuchen
charlas cuando lean lo pregunten un poco
como el emprendedor
antes de arrancar en general es cierto
que emprendedores que ahora arrancan y
cambian mucho cuando cuando empiezan a
emprender pero si ustedes ven en general
los emprendedores antes de empezar con
el emprendimiento ya son gente
apasionada o sea son gente que le pone
mucha energía lo que hace ya son gente
que funcionan fundamentalmente disfrutan
lo que hacen porque en realidad la
pasión la base de la pasión es disfrutar
lo que estamos haciendo y la forma de
hacerlo y la forma que hacen los
emprendedores que nos para emprender es
fundamentalmente lo que tienen es pasión
por hacer disfrutan hacer cosas
disfrutan el día a día porque también en
esta trampa uno cree que por cuando una
emprendedor gusta del proyecto que
quiere está haciendo lo que quiere y la
verdad que gran parte del día y ni
siquiera hay días enteros que uno no
está haciendo lo que quiere la verdad
que aún nos pasa a todos aún
emprendiendo hay días completos que uno
está haciendo cosas que te marca la
responsabilidad la agenda las
obligaciones y es mentira que estás todo
el día haciendo
entonces una cosa importante que creo
que hay que cultivar es y es una
característica los emprendedores sí que
es gente que le gusta hacer y lo van a
ver que hoy tiene un proyecto y mañanas
en otro totalmente variado y se digan
después responsables sociales en general
emprendedor una persona que le gusta
hacer y una característica para generar
esa pasión es empezar a querer ya tener
pasión y ahí a querer lo que uno hace
quiero que nos toque sea que hoy nos
toca estar en un trabajo que nos toca
empieza con un proyecto que fracasa o lo
que sea es tener pasión es tener es
querer lo que uno hace y tener ganas de
hacer el segundo aspecto es el tema de
la el optimismo también cuando uno habla
con escucha la charla de los
emprendedores o la charla con emprender
lo escuché y usted dice pero qué energía
que tiene la tiene clarísima es por re
positivo cree que lo va a ser cree que
lo va a lograr y parece lo mismo aparece
que los emprendedores son gente que que
sintonizó otro canal que está viendo
otra película
y acá les quiero también hacer hincapié
que vayamos a ver un poquito en que se
basa creo yo el óptimo y los
emprendedores y tengo una anécdota al
respecto una vez que estaba en la
empresa estamos con un problema
importante y una persona con la que
trabaja que trabajamos vino a mi oficina
y me dice mira aquí está este problema
mire qué te parece que hagamos la verdad
que la veo muy difícil y la hora que una
situación muy compleja y charlamos entre
los dos intercambiamos opiniones
momentos ya sabes que me parece que
tenemos que hacer esto hay que hacer
estas cosas y hay que lograr esto
en 2 minuto la persona se levanta cuando
va a salir de mi oficina con la mano en
la puerta y me dice si la verdad que
viene con una idea que esto estaba
muerto y la verdad que la tenés clara me
dice siempre que vengo acá tenés una
idea para como resolverlo
así que me voy optimista cierra la
puerta y con seba digo la verdad que yo
optimista decirme que tenía confianza lo
que vamos a hacer la verdad es que no
estaba tan pesimista como él lo había
tan grave como lo estaba viendo él y acá
a partir de entonces empecé también a
presionar esto el optimismo y lo tenemos
el emprendedor no es que tiene la bola
de cristal y que está seguro de lo que
va a obtener el optimismo de la actitud
emprendedora parte en la confianza de
que lo que vamos a hacer y lo que el
esfuerzo que va a poner y que vamos a
intentar el optimismo el emprendedor se
basa en aún con la incertidumbre agustín
saber si va a resultar aún si sabe si va
a tener seguridad darle para adelante e
intentarlo intentarlo cuando hay baja
probabilidad de intentarlo y esto es
fundamental y estos son las cosas que se
pueden informando en las pequeñas
decisiones no cuando meto conexión
importante sino en el día a día cuando
te o cuando tengo un problema chiquito y
digo ven a ver y no sé la verdad que hay
poca problema en el emprendedor al éxito
emprendedores y bueno lo voy a intentar
lo voy a intentar y esto es fundamental
en toén dos cosas primero porque dan
a poco y cuando uno cuando uno tiene
objetivo puede fallar pero por lo menos
lo intenta pero lo segundo que hace esto
es que el emprendedor también cuando
falla porque tienen fallamos mucho y
cometemos muchos errores el emprender la
única confianza que tiene es saber que
dice mira por lo menos lo intenté hice
todo lo posible no salió pero lo intente
y eso no se frustra entonces esta
actitud de optimismo el emprendedor no
es una cosa mágica no es tener la bola
de cristal no es saber más que el resto
es saber que uno le va a poner todo
empuje y lo va a ser
este es el aspecto también que está
relacionado con estos y el protagonismo
los emprendedores son gente en real en
protagonista mit y che que están en
todos lados que están siempre haciendo
cosas y en realidad esta actitud
emprendedora es la que siempre busca
transformar y hacer cosas distintas por
este protagonismo el emprendedor se basa
digo yo lo digo con todos ejemplo que
son una metáfora muy simple pero para
que entiendan lo que les quiero
transmitir si uno habla con un
emprendedor no le va a decir si estaría
bueno como un asado te va a decir mira
hagamos asado vamos a nada si me
preguntan emprender o cómo está el día
nos va a decir mira la temperatura se
está no hay viento está lindo pero si
mira esta preocupación en la playa está
para que salgamos a correr la actitud
de transformadora y protagonista de los
emprendedores es hablar y evaluar la
realidad y pensar las cosas en términos
de acción de lo que voy a hacer
emprendedor no es que está mirando lo
que como deberían ser las cosas como
debía estar la economía como deberían
ser el mercado como dirían ser los
clientes sino decir qué voy a hacer para
que para que esto cambie y luego poner
ponerlo todo en acción y lo que no puedo
hacerlo yo y bueno no no no es una
persona que está continuamente viendo lo
que debería ser la cómo deben ser las
cosas sino como la quiere lograr y ellos
también son cosas que se pueden formando
en el tiempo y en las pequeñas
decisiones empezará a ponerse y evaluar
y opinar en acción no opinar en la queja
de opinión luego mirar la de afuera y
ésta también son pequeñas cosas que hay
que ir formando para que cuando te toca
un proyecto más grande todo un desafío
más grande tener esta actitud de
protagonista y el último punto en cuarto
punto que les quiero marcar es el tema
de el propósito
vieron que últimamente nuestros padres
podrían gente que decíamos que vivían
pensando en el futuro ahorrando para el
mañana pensando y nosotros hoy las
generaciones más jóvenes o más joven
incluso que la mía está mucho pensando
en el hoy en el vivido presente en ser
feliz hoy yo digo que en esta en esta en
este marco de entre el futuro del pasado
los protagonistas viven
con un propósito vive en el hoy con un
propósito lo que hoy hace entre los
productos emprende lo que está haciendo
y le va a decir no lo que físicamente
está en ese momento haciendo sino lo que
con ello piensa lograr esa visión de
propósito de un para que el emprendedor
piensa mucho todo lo que hacen para que
lo que está haciendo tiene un sentido
más puntual de hoy y ese propósito es
muy importante porque primero la energía
primero de a poco pero después también
el trabajo emprendedor siempre trabaja
en equipo y juntar y trabaja con otra
gente y lograr motivar otros grupos y la
verdad que parte desde la visión muchas
seis de los portales por aquello en la
palabra cuando arrancamos que eran
visión la visión del emprendedor parte
de esto de lo que está haciendo tiene un
propósito y ese propósito termina siendo
la construcción de la visión y después
de otro por el otro importante del
propósito es que también permite superar
la frustración porque hay un problema
muy grave cuando uno emprende y en la
vida y en los ejemplos que vimos hasta
un rato también hablan de esto la verdad
que la vida tiene muchos sinsabores
muchas dificultades y muchos fracasos
y la verdad que la única forma de no
quedarse inmovilizado de no de no
retrotraerse con los fracasos es tener
un propósito en las cosas entonces
cuando me equivoco cuando nos sale no
importa porque en realidad es parte de
un camino algo más allá estoy en otro
aspecto importante también que creo que
se puede cultivar antes de empezar con
un proyecto y empezar a hacer cosas con
un propósito y decir bueno hoy me toca
estar acá hoy me toca este trabajo y me
toca este proyecto pero es un propósito
es parte de un proyecto y algo que
hubiera más allá
en definitiva lo que quería compartir
hoy más allá de los que quieran
emprender o no emprender yo quería
hablar de actitud emprendedora que se
puso en la vida con muchas cosas
yo quería reflexionar no era solamente
para que el que quiere emprender sino
creo que son valores actitudes
emprendedoras que pueden servir y mi
mensaje era este sea cual sea tu
presente sea cual sea tu proyecto sea
cual sea tu sueño lo importante la
actitud emprendedora que va a permitir
marcar la diferencia
[Música]
ah
y